un deux trois quatre super une plage de
sotchi sur les bords de la mer noire
cet après midi une petite troupe de
danseuses centre elle
voilà là c'est fatigant il fait chaud
soleil en plus ce soir elles doivent
assurer un show dans un club de la ville
il ya une concurrence énorme ici machine
de très belles filles viennent de toute
la région et les hommes sont en minorité
alors on va se perfectionner tous les
jours savoir se montrer et c'est
vraiment du boulot
sotchi un nouvel eldorado où les plus
belles femmes du pays viennent tenter
leur chance
sotchi c'est la plus grande station
balnéaire de russie à plus de 1500 km au
sud de moscou une ville qui s'étend sur
près de 150 km entre les côtes de la mer
noire et les montagnes du caucase la
capitale de la riviera russes pour des
centaines de milliers de vacanciers
sabine a souri allez vas-y souri à maman
sotchi sous les feux des projecteurs
depuis qu'ils ont été attribués les jeux
olympiques d'hiver de 2014 des jo à
sotchi
c'est le résultat des efforts de
vladimir poutine qui vient souvent qui
dévaler les pistes déguster une bière
fraîche devant un match de foot ou
recevoir ses vieux amis
mais cjo font aussi des malheureux comme
alex hayes un ancien policier sa maison
doit être rasée pour laisser place à la
nouvelle gare olympique
il se bat pour la sauver vous savez pour
se défendre en russie le seul moyen
c'est d'avoir beaucoup d'argent pour
donner des enveloppes ce que moi
personnellement je ne fais pas une
bataille difficile
seul contre tous un combat perdu
d'avancé mois les questions vous faites
mais arrêtez les si on va prendre mes
affaires pour alex hayes sa maison
natale ne sera bientôt plus qu'un
souvenir
il est loin d'être le seul avec les jo à
sotchi se refait un nouveau visage toute
la ville est en chantier des bulldozer
qui poussent les jeunes à passer leurs
vacances de l'autre côté de la mer noire
à kazantip le festival le plus fou à
l'est on y vient de toute l'europe
benjamins 1 français de 36 ans gerland
dancefloor
il faut respecter la programmation
canton d'ici d'ailleurs ces six heures
saab est en soi un pays de sées soit
pays du bonheur
en ukraine ils sont 200 milles fêtards à
venir transgresser les codes pendant
deux semaines du pur délire des dizaines
de pistes de danse de la musique 24
heures sur 24 sur le sable de crimée
l'oeuvre folle d'un russe mégalo le
voici qui parcourent son royaume en
véhicules électriques dans ses bras son
fils de deux ans je vous le dis en toute
sincérité je suis un dictateur un
dictateur de la fête au projet démesuré
je veux une représentation à l'onu
l'indépendance la reconnaissance de
notre république et de ses droits
ici la jeunesse dorée bien s'oublier le
temps d'un été
pendant que sotchi se prépare à
accueillir sur ses plages familiales
un événement planétaire voyage le long
de la riviera russe
[Musique]
un quartier populaire de sotchi loin des
plages et de ces fêtes vip marina 19 ans
avec ces drôles de bigoudis se prépare à
aller travailler non d'un g20 à prendre
des forces avant mais je ne dois pas
mangé beaucoup je dois faire attention
je ne peux pas être gonflé avant de
danser
marina est danseuse dans une boîte de
nuit de sotchi arrivé il ya deux ans ici
elle vit seule
loin de sa famille restée dans son
village natal au centre de la russie
seule trace de sa vie d'avant ce coussin
un souvenir d'enfance
j'y suis très attaché
c'est la seule photo de mes parents que
j'ai je la regarde et je pense à eux je
vais pleurer
à peine sorti de l'adolescence des rêves
plein la tête et des étoiles dans les
yeux
elle a tout quitté pour les paillettes
de sotchi
[Musique]
c'était comme une obsession
d'autant plus que je savais déjà que ce
serait une capitale olympique plusieurs
fois par semaine marina danse près de
huit heures par nuit dans les clubs de
la ville il est 19 heures direction los
blacks à une boîte ouverte il ya deux
mois par un richissime homme d'affaires
de moscou dans les autres établissements
les gens parfois me touchait ou me
renverser du champagne dessus alors à
l'aube la cas je voulais absolument est
entré on était c'est le meilleur
établissement à sotchi le meilleur le
plus cher surtout dans ce club qui
surplombe la mer noire une table coûte
1000 euros et salut tu as fait quoi tes
cheveux à peine arrivé marina et suit
les reproches de la coiffeuse l évasion
installe toi elle s'est bouclé les
cheveux pensant bien faire
tu aurait au moins pu les enlever tout
seul mais je n'ai fait pour que ce soit
bouclée tu l'as fait pour être sûr que
je m'en occupe way
oh là là ils vont être si prisé que ça
on va mettre du gel calme-toi pression
dans les loges
toutes les filles s'activent
et une heure après et voilà marine a
retrouvé le sourire et ses cheveux
lisses assez trop bien ça me plaît
beaucoup
pour elle comme pour ses collègues c'est
une soirée spéciale elles doivent être
parfaites elles attendent l'arrivée
d'une star en russie
le chanteur d'un des plus grands boys
band du pays j'ai hâte qu'il arrive il
est complètement dingue on va allumer le
feu même plus la gérante du club
aliona semble dépasser la soirée
d'aujourd'hui est vraiment importante
même primordial pour nous il est
beaucoup de travail à faire en amont
tu vois je n'ai même pas eu le temps
encore de me changer je ne ressemble à
rien toi je suis encore en tongs
mais je fais semblant que tout va bien
genre l'aube la can n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur
celui qui les rend tout fébrile c'est
lui seront qu'un andreia pologne- f
alors c'est bon tout roule 1 comment ça
se passe il ya un mot de passe une liste
pour mes invités né à sotchi
il a décidé d'y fêter ses quarante trois
ans ce soir il va donner un concert
privé pour ses amis petit briefing avec
les danseuses marina emmitouflé dans sa
couverture semble impressionné en
fonction de mes chansons vous pouvez
danser à deux ou à quatre enfin vous
savez on connaît toutes tes chansons tu
sais
merci ma chérie et marina mais pas peur
mon coeur tout ira bien
andrei comme toutes les stars en russie
habite à moscou toi ça fait si longtemps
mais reste l'enfant chéri de sotchi ce
tce devenu notre ville depuis mon
enfance j'aime beaucoup que cette
station balnéaire ordinaire et populaire
en russie soit en train de devenir un
vrai centre international retour en
coulisses
marina met la touche finale avant de
monter sur scène
[Musique]
je mets de l'huile pour que maps aubry
vue de la scène ce sera pour dans la vie
je suis différente
le travail me change complètement je
suis une hausse par rapport à tout à
l'heure je suis plus complexé c'est
grâce à la danse
il est minuit la soirée peut commencer
des dj venu spécialement de moscou
quatre pistes de danse marina et ses
copines vont assurer le show pour les
600 personnes présentes dont drei ravi
des touristes vip prêt à débourser des
milliers d'euros pour quelques heures de
fête sur les bords de la mer noire
[Applaudissements]
autour de la star de rentrer en piste
[Musique]
première chanson son plus gros tube
celui qui l'a fait connaître
de la bonne pop vendu à des millions
d'exemplaires
[Musique]
c'est la soirée à la mode ici c'est
hyper branché ici c'est bien plus
choquant parce que l'ambiance est à son
maximum pour marina un dernier passage
avant de faire les comptes de la soirée
[Musique]
je te regarde et danse et était bien
ouais mais je sais pas ce qu'ils ont ce
soir le salaire c'est 60 euros mais je
n'ai eu que 25 euros de pourboire
bon ce n'est pas si mauvais même si
d'habitude c'est minimum 115 euros pour
la soirée
il est 4 heures du matin marina rentrer
chez elle aliona la gérante semble bien
moins stressé que tout à l'heure
elle a réalisé 100 mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires champagne à volonté
et amuse-gueules à prix exorbitants
andrei et ses amis n'ont pas regardé à
la dépense ici c'est la russie mais en
fait ça n'a rien à voir avec le reste du
pays tous les gens qui viennent à sotchi
me disent que ça ressemble plus à à
monaco elle saint-tropez même ibiza loin
du standing de l'eau black à la nuit ici
ce sont surtout les boîtes de nuit de la
marina des bars et des discothèques pas
cher en enfilade le long de la côte des
clubs bien moins glamour ou des jeunes
en vacances
entraîné par des danseuses qui n'ont
rien à voir avec marina viennent surtout
boire
plus fort on y va tous tout le monde
danse l'alcool fléau des vacances sur
les bords de la mer noire
et vas-y fais gaffe c'est toi allez
c'est bon de temps toi l'été la ville de
sotchi doit appeler des renforts dès
juillet une centaine de policiers
débarquent reconnaissables à leur
uniforme d'un autre âge
le sergent atrium à gauche vient de la
région de moscou il y à un million de
touristes qui viennent chaque été ça
fait trois fois plus de personnes que
durant l'année et à cause de l'alcool
les gens n'arrivent plus à se contrôler
toutacoo appel du central oui je vous
reçois
[Musique]
on a besoin de nous à l'entrée d'une
boîte d'un papa si pressé il arrive
devant une discothèque où une bagarre a
eu lieu il ya à peine cinq minutes
la victime c'est cet homme il appelle un
ami à l'aide
je suis là où il ya de la musique vient
maintenant nous cherchons à lui parler
ce qui dérange le videur du lieu vous
allez arrêter de tourner c'est une de
tes petites bêtes qui m'a attaqué tu
vois bien qu'il ya la télé française qui
filme ici et donc je peux rien dire à
quoi bon abruti je suis très calme mois
alors arrête ne commence pas à
m'insulter
nos deux sergents eux ne font absolument
rien nous leur demandons pourquoi
personne ne sera inquiété
vous savez c'est difficile de travailler
ici on ne peut pas tout faire quand il
est pris à partie par des clients de
l'établissement
n'oubliez pas de dire aussi un quand ils
tabassent parce que ça il le destin
tu as dis pas que tu tapes et en plus
vous faites rien c'est vrai ce qu'on dit
il c'est c'est vrai quoi on en foutez
pas une rien vous ne bossez par eos aval
à wasquehal mais cette jeune fille a
tout vu de l'agression
cette nuit dans le secteur 5 bagarre
aurait eu lieu mais aucune arrestation
allait bien là ça suffit
arrêt à temps je termine je voulais vous
dire sotchi c1 trois rats sotchi un trou
à rats ou les jeunes en fin de nuit
viennent s'échouer sur la plage n'ont
pas de caméra ce jeune a trop vu on
voulait juste vérifier s'il dormait ou
pire va vraiment falloir que vous
arrêtiez de filmer et je vous promets
qu'on va vous emmener au poste il faut
continuer
les policiers sont à cran sur les côtes
de la mer noire
sotchi station balnéaire populaire mais
aussi le lieu de résidence d'été des
plus grands comme vladimir poutine quand
il n'est pas à la chasse à cheval à la
mer à la pêche ou en communion avec des
grues en plein vol le président russe m
y recevoir les grands de ce monde où ses
amis de toujours qui l'accueille ici
chez lui
sotchi dont le destin a basculé le 4
juillet 2007 le jour où le cio lui
attribue les jeux depuis la ville se
refait un nouveau visage de la côte
jusqu'aux montagnes avec ses onze
installations sportives dernier cri et
près de 200 chantiers pour moderniser
les routes d'aéroports la gare ou
construire des hôtels cinq étoiles un
changement radical que paye au prix fort
des milliers d'habitants menacée
d'expulsion
comme alex hayes 45 ans un ancien
policier sa maison au bord de mer
gênerait la construction de la future
gare voilà c'est ici qu'on habite et
vous voyez on a écrit les gigots prive
les gens de logements un peu plus aussi
on a marqué ici des gens vivent et on ne
partira pas tant qu'on n'a pas obtenu un
logement correct il y a encore un an
plus d'une centaine de personnes
vivaient ici dans une vingtaine de
maisons
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus que la
sienne
[Musique]
regardez voilà comment on vit là le gaz
évidence et ballon ici c'est comme ça
qu'on fait la cuisine et ça c'est
générateur pour la lumière y a pas d'eau
l'eau a été coupée
rené voir les toilettes et la douche on
en est réduit à ça des conditions de vie
insalubres
il est vite ici avec son fils de 14 ans
leurs voisins se sont résignés au départ
mais eux refusent depuis novembre 2010
alexei se bat seul sans avocat contre
l'état et la société de construction
pour l'instant son dossier est en
attente de jugement
un court répit face aux menaces et aux
intimidations pas se regarder au mois de
janvier à minuit tout le monde dormait
il faisait froid et on nous a lancé une
pierre
ça a cassé la vitre et pourquoi ils ont
fait ça pour nous faire partir pour
qu'on parte pour qu'on habite plus ici
parce que la maison les empêche
d'encercler le terrain alex hayes et son
fils font de la résistance
mais 3000 personnes ont déjà été délogés
trois mois après notre première visite
nous retournons chez eux dont d'abord
pour commencer on va au moins prendre
les boîtes de conserve
alex hayes et son fils font leurs
bagages le jour qu'il redoutait tant
vient d'arriver
vu que je ne sais pas du tout où on va
passer la nuit
il faudra qu'on ait quelque chose à
manger la veille alex hayes a reçu
l'avis de démolition avant que les
bulldozer n'entre en action
il va être expulsé tous ces efforts ont
été vains
vous savez pour se défendre en russie le
seul moyen c'est d'avoir beaucoup
d'argent pour donner des enveloppes et
ça moi personnellement je ne le fais pas
je le sais par expérience maintenant en
russie
personne ne va vous aider
voilà les u6 sont arrivés ils viennent
juste d'arriver
vous allez laisser rentrer non je n'ai
pas l'intention de laisser rentrer
penser que je vais laisser rentrer des
gens pour qu'ils cassent ma maison
jamais sinon mes enfants qu'est ce
qu'ils vont me dire ils sont plus d'une
dizaine policiers huissier ouvriers à
s'activer
ils viennent d'ouvrir la première porte
de la maison alex hayes est barricadé au
premier étage
il enregistre tout pour garder des prix
ils ont presque ouvert
bonjour bonjour
pour certains il n'est pas très bon
allez sortez s'il vous plaît et vous
vous êtes ici pourquoi surprise des
policiers à la vue de notre caméra c'est
moi qui les ai laissés entrer sortait
sinon je vais vous aider à sortir mais
laissez moi prendre mes affaires
les gars qu'est ce que vous faites mais
qu'est ce que vous faites à l'essor de
la soeur de large peut prendre mes
affaires en moins mais laissez moi
prendre mes affaires
on va vous les amener une seule personne
va monter va les prendre et un la caméra
les forces de l'ordre pense ne plus être
filmés
c'est quand même ma maison à moi je ne
comprends pas restez où vous êtes
qu'est ce que vous faites j'ai mon
enfant là bas lâchez-moi lâchez moi mais
lâchez moi je vous dis
fin de la partie pour alex frei la
démolition de la maison où il est né
commence il ne peut qu assisté
impuissant au spectacle
vous voyez je suis un sdf maintenant je
ne sais plus quoi dire comme ça à cause
des jeux olympiques et de coupable de
tout ça c'est le gouvernement local qui
n'a rien fait mais la mairie également
qui m'a promis de m'aider pour que je ne
reste pas dehors et qui n'a rien fait
non plus
pendant plusieurs heures les ouvriers
entassent dans la boue les maigres
affaires qu alex hayes a réussi à sauver
sous la pluie ce matin d'hiver alexei et
son fils quittent leurs maisons dans
cette voiture prêtée par un ami sans
savoir où aller
l'histoire d'alex haye
l'envers du décor que les autorités
préfèrent cacher depuis l'annnonce des
jeux des pubs comme celles ci passent en
boucle
n'a pas été géniale passe les nièces
quelques rillettes strana gâteau il se
trouve à genoux montréalaise de nomos
habitude j me aline prdf sotchi tout
doit être beau et briller aucun couac
n'est tolérée sotchi 2014 doit être
montré comme un succès sans tache
[Musique]
deuxième jour d'une visite de presse
balade et d'installations en
installation journalistes russes et
internationaux sont là pour relayer le
discours d'une machine de communication
bien huilée et surveillés au millimètre
nous arrivons sur le site du futur parc
olympique de suite
oksana la chargée de com en tee shirt
blanc nous surveille explique lui qu'il
peut pas filmer ici vos papiers s'il
vous plaît il est interdit de filmer ici
rentrer à l'intérieur s'il vous plaît
nous franchissons la première barrière
de sécurité
mais à peine quelques mètres plus loin
deuxième vérification la sécurité des
installations olympiques c'est la
priorité
les normes de sécurité sont très
strictes par exemple pour tous les poids
lourds on a mis en place un système de
scanner une obsession sécuritaire avant
même le début des jeux sur le site
olympique première halte là juste
derrière se trouve une des arènes de
notre parc
direction cette installation sportive le
palais de glace qui accueillera plus de
12000 spectateurs pendant les jeux
oksana donne le flambeau à vladimir
l'ingénieur en chef le seul ici
autorisés à répondre aux journalistes
vladimir est compétent pour vous parler
de notre parc petit discours officiel
avant d'arriver sur la patinoire
vous voyez bien le parc là et toutes les
installations qui l'entourent ça c'est
notre grand palais de glace et ça c'est
le club de glace
cette patinoire accueillera les matchs
de hockey vladimir fait le boulot répond
aux journalistes
mais au moindre écart la chargée de com
le reprend nous pouvons rentrer par le
terrain et ressortir du côté de la salle
de conférence non ça veut dire non de
rentrer par le haut la salle de
conférence la salle de presse et puis
c'est tout ça peut être pas mal est
intéressant ce n'est pas les
journalistes qui vont décider de ce
qu'ils peuvent voir ou de quoi parler
moi j'ai fait ça spontanément je voulais
faire au mieux et bien c'est non oksana
n'en démord pas c'est niet
la visite se poursuit à marche forcée
allez on y va on monte dans le bus suite
du tour organisé nous partons pour le
centre iceberg impressionnant du haut de
ses 34 m ici se dérouleront les
compétitions de patinage artistique et
de vitesse
une visite toujours sous l'oeil avisé
d'oksana alexandre vous savez quoi dire
un
une petite piqûre de rappel avant de
répondre à ces journalistes russes
[Musique]
nous avons des systèmes de
refroidissement dernier cri qui
permettent de passer d'une température à
l'autre sans changer la structure de la
glace tous ne sont pas dupes de cette
opération séduction
non on ne nous dit pas tout par exemple
c'est très difficile d'obtenir des
informations sur l'aspect financier des
jeux savoir combien les installations
coûtent quel est le vrai budget des jeux
olympiques
la somme serait démesuré 36 milliards
d'euros
les jeux d'hiver à sotchi sont les plus
chers jamais organisée 26 fois plus que
les précédents jeux avant de couverts en
2010 notamment à cause des retards et de
la corruption
après plus de deux heures de visite
dernière halte dans une énième patinoire
et toujours des contrôles tatillons
regardent ils sont tous là tout le monde
a montré sa pièce d'identité
tiens regarde elle est là donc c'est bon
tu as tout tu as tout le monde
si la sécurité est une obsession pour
les organisateurs c'est parce qu'une
menace pèse sur ces jeux d'hiver dans
ces montagnes se déroule une guerre qui
n'en a pas le nom à l'aise de sotchi en
tchétchénie et dans les autres provinces
du caucase du nord
un conflit oppose moscou séparatistes
islamistes
en 2012 les combats ont fait près de 300
morts
l'armée russe est toujours présente et
les menaces bien réelles
l'année dernière les forces spéciales
ont déjoué un attentat sans ses frappes
et sotchi et empêcher les jo une guerre
menée par cet homme dokou oumarov un
chef rebelle tchétchène
cette vidéo a été postée sur internet en
juillet dernier en tant que moudjahidine
notre devoir c'est de ne pas laisser cjo
se tenir et ce par tous les moyens call
là nous donne on doit faire tout ce qui
est possible pour empêcher cjo de satan
dernières attaques perpétrées par le
groupe d'oumarov cet attentat commis le
21 octobre dernier contre un bus dans le
sud du pays six morts et de nombreux
blessés
l'attentât le plus meurtrier depuis
trois ans en russie une attaque kamikaze
attribué à cette femme de 30 ans
originaire du caucase
pour ceux qui veulent fuir sotchi ces
foules ses travaux et ses menaces
le meilleur endroit pour passer ses
vacances c'est de l'autre côté de la mer
noire sur la péninsule de crimée à kazan
tiff
la riviera russe des jeunes sexy et
branché bienvenue dans l'un des dix plus
gros festivals au monde où près de 200
mille personnes vient de faire la fête
sur une dizaine de dancefloor pendant
deux semaines au bord de la mer noire
un bout de sable de trois hectares loués
en concession par un russe mégalo qui a
réussi en seulement vingt ans à faire
d'un simple rassemblement techno un
énorme coup marketing
kazan type se veut une république de la
fête avec ces sonos 24 heures sur 24
ses bars ses chambres d'hôtel ses
boutiques et ses codes bien spécifiques
[Musique]
ce soir c'est la soirée d'ouverture dans
les rues de la ville
nous rencontrons jérémie 25 ans et ses
amis vincent et arnaud ces trois
bordelais sont venus fêter la fin de
leurs études à 3000 kilomètres de la
france sur le chemin du festival les
rencontres sont faciles
[Musique]
c'est de l'oxygène dans un peu en prend
d'oxygène jérémy vient d'inhaler du
protoxyde d'azoté un gaz à effet le fort
is an et hallucinogène vendus sur le
festival à 3 euros le ballon c'est légal
et il n'est que 23 heures la soirée
commence dans une heure entré à kazan
type c'est comme franchir une frontière
il faut passer un portique de sécurité
gardé par des mercenaires ukrainien nous
ne pouvons le film etc en caméra cachée
[Musique]
d'abord scanner un pas sa reconnaissance
faciale et montrer patte blanche et
enlève tes lunettes et ta casquette il
faut que je te vois
un passeport pour la république de la
fait contrôler par d'anciens militaires
ce qui n'a pas l'air de déranger des
français et le petit palais ça c'est le
blizzard la république de gaz 1 tipsa ça
ça nous permet de rentrer ici de sortir
comme on veut dans un comme si on était
le sas de sécurité est un droit de
passage de 260 euros le prix à payer
pour avoir accès au pays de la fête
pendant deux semaines
[Musique]
où les français comptent bien s'oublier
la cause anti peser l'opening qu'on va
s'éclater histoire
à
je dis ça [__]
[Musique]
des dj venus de moscou sont déjà en
place arnaud à peine arrivé essaye d'en
profiter
devenir un autre le temps d'un soir
c'est ce que propose kazan type
ici on ne parle pas d'un festival mais
d'une république avec sa frontière et
ses symboles comme ces drapeaux et ses
signes de reconnaissance ses valises
jaune marquée du cycle z
le logo de kazantip
[Musique]
il est minuit coup d'envoi le show est
démesurée avec les meilleurs artificiers
mondiaux les derniers costumes high tech
une soirée financée par des russes
milliardaires protégés dans leur carré
viiip est entourée des plus belles
femmes
tout est fait pour séduire ces fêtards
qu'on appelle ici des citoyens une
jeunesse des pays de l'est
persuadé de vivre une cérémonie unique
au monde derrière toute cette mise en
scène un russe de 45 ans qui voit les
choses en grand
ici tout le monde l'appelle le président
nikita premier un homme au budget
illimité et qui sait vendre ces images
ont été tournées par son propre
dispositif digne des plus grandes
chaînes pour ne rien louper de la fête
4 heures du matin dans une chambre
d'hôtel aux abords du festival
benjamin 36 ans et sa petite amie
ukrainienne se réveille
tu sais où sont montées les fans et mon
pass là c'est l'heure d'aller au boulot
l'année benjamin travaille dans le
milieu de la nuit à paris l'été il gère
au club sur le festival
comme tous les jours de la techno il va
en avoir plein les oreilles pendant 17
heures
le soleil va pas se trouver dans une
heure donc même si là il est nuit noire
d'abord c'est la meilleure heure où
surtout ok les plus grands dj benjamin
viata kazantip depuis neuf ans devenu un
proche de nikita le grand chef il a un
traitement privilégié
nous arrivons par une entrée vip
ça lui vaut pas s'il vous plaît et je
sais qu'ils se sont des journalistes
pour tenir le choc benjamin a ses
petites habitudes dans ce bar du
territoire benjamin est maintenant d'
attaque pour prendre la température des
clubs qu'on appelle ici des flores est à
l'envers et retrouver les dj qui
viennent d'arriver
[Musique]
salut mon pote ça va ouais super et toi
c'est l'heure de prendre les rênes du
aymon son flore bonjour salut chef l'un
des plus sélects du territoire à
quelques mètres de là nous croisons
jérémy qui lui semble avoir commencé sa
soirée il ya bien longtemps
je vais aller me prendre une bière et je
rentre me coucher tu va coucher
oui ok à demain avec 120 sont ni arnaud
ses deux acolytes du parti pour les amis
retrouvés
c'est lors d'un dernier verre tu parle
anglais
ok alors de vodka avec du jus d'orange
et de la grenadine
ici comme dans la trentaine de bars et
de restaurants de kazantip les prix sont
fixés à la tête du client
8 ok allez merci 8 euros les deux heures
c'est un peu comme en europe
ça dépend la soirée ça dépend des jours
les fléchir un peu
il est 6 heures du matin dans quelques
morceaux les jeunes bordelais iront se
coucher fin de soirée pour jérémy alors
qu'au même moment la journée commence
pour benjamin il doit gérer un imprévu
ce dj russe termine dans 10 minutes et
personne n'est là pour reprendre le
flambeau sprint matinale pour benjamin
qui doit aller récupérer sa djette sur
une autre piste à l'autre bout du
territoire
il ya des règles ici tu ça dérègle oui
il ya des règles un ça va c'est pas la
fin du monde
la retardataire c'est dj blondy elle
vient de londres
tu dois respecter la programmation si on
te dit 6 heures 6 heures la jeune femme
termine est tout simplement une bière
dans un autre bar benjamin essaye de
gagner du temps combien de temps tu peux
jouer encore bah je sais pas une demi
heure ça irait ok pas de problème
bon je suis désolé mais on a encore un
peu de temps
affaire réglée la tension retombe
[Applaudissements]
toute la matinée blondie jeu va jouer
pour les plus accros benjamin lui va
pouvoir aller se détendre comme tous les
après midi sur cette lagune au spot
connu des pays de l'est benjamin il fait
un sport aujourd'hui à la mode du kite
surfing
cela te croit faire la fête le soir et
le sport la journée a fait vraiment bon
match j'ai trouvé mon paradis un sport à
l'origine du festival
kita lorsqu'il est parti pour la
première fois en crimée en 92 c'était
pour faire du windsurf soirée un feu de
camp avec de la musique c'est comme ça a
commencé les premières fêtes de cazaux
aussi sur la bien fait avec 20 sportif
la première année c'est vrai c'est à 200
puis 400 puis 2000 une réussite
nous avons voulu rencontrer l'homme qui
tire les ficelles de kazantip c'est lui
nikita difficile à attraper à bord de sa
machine
son fils de 2 ans dans les bras
encadrée par ses deux attachées de
presse le président a bien voulu nous
accorder quelques minutes d'interview
non c'est pas bon là ce n'est pas du
tout préparés tu comprends je m'en fiche
d'être assis ou debout c'est juste que
là bon allez qu'ils posent leurs
questions et vite
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps pouvez vous
ne posez que quelques questions et
rapidement s'il vous plaît début de la
rencontre avec le patron cette
construction est là tout simplement
vieilli et j'ai décidé de la démo les
uns du haut de son piédestal
le chef contente le son royaume et ce
qu'ils considèrent comme ces sujets à
vrai dire je ne suis pas un adepte de la
démocratie ce n'est pas le modèle le
plus performant de la société et quant à
l'efficacité vous pouvez le constater
ici le peuple est heureux je peux vous
le dire en toute sincérité je suis un
dictateur le dictateur nikita nous fait
part de ses projets d'avenir en toute
simplicité
je veux une représentation à l'onu
l'indépendance la reconnaissance de
notre république et de ses droits
personne ne sait comment créer un état
vous savez notre jeu et elle est si loin
que tout avenir est possible aujourd'hui
nous sommes un état de jeu imaginaire
mais ensuite nous allons devenir un vrai
talent 15 minutes chrono
pas une seconde de plus nikita est un
homme d'état près c'est une dictature du
bonheur auquel goutte sans complexe tous
les fêtards de kazantip il est 15 heures
sur la plage à côté des derniers jeux à
la mode comme c'est hydro jet la fête
bat toujours son plein
nous retrouvons notre groupe de français
alors que les vacanciers à la
maintenance en ukraine
non alors dans ce qu'ils ont ici ce sera
le blizzard l'ukrainien quoi je pense
que ça l'est déjà mais tous les
européens
et les américains pourront venir ici je
pense qu il ya elle s'apprête cette
naïveté on va dire mais on ne doit plus
à faire ce qu'on veut
il n'y a pas trop de limites qui est
c'est vrai que par rapport aux autres
festivals watts là on est en droit de
kazan tiff est un territoire où tout
semblerait possible
l'abus d'alcool y est courant et les
ballons hallucinogènes ce fameux
protoxyde d'azoté se vante 24 heures sur
24 en toute légalité
malgré la présence des mercenaires
ukrainiens et des caméras de
surveillance des jeunes fument du
cannabis sans se cacher c'est facile
d'en trouver
oui oui ce n'est pas cher c'est possible
alors que le territoire se veut hyper
contrôlée il suffit d'aller un peu plus
loin sur la plage à quelques mètres du
festival un café une adresse connue des
habitués
nous nous y rendons en caméra cachée à
peine arrivée nous nous faisons abordé
par cet homme
j'ai de la cocaïne et de la mdma sait
combien la cocaïne c'est 200 $ et bien
d'où la cocaïne elle vient de bolivie et
la mdma sais combien c'est 100 euros
regarda les bonnes et tu peux la fumée
aussi ces trafics de drogue n'existe
qu'en période de festival avant de nous
quitter
benjamin nous fait partager l'une des
coutumes de kazantip le coucher de
soleil
il est 19 heures surtout ne rien manquer
du moment karima tu viens avec nous tu
veux pour quelque chose
je voudrais de lauzes sans bulles s'il
vous plaît de l'eau plate
bien entourée entre son ex et sa
nouvelle amie la musique s'arrête c'est
le seul moment de silence à kazantip
d'ailleurs au moment du dernier rayon de
soleil cette tradition tout le monde
doit applaudir
la mer noire dans sa version glamour
mais aussi plus à l'est des plages
bondées en juillet août
allez on en prend un c'est bon à sotchi
à quelques mètres de la foule à l'abri
des regards
deux hommes sont en train de se changer
herbert 26 ans et raymond 32 ans ils
sont tous les deux camerounais on va
descendre le petit boulot local 1,9
l'année ils sont étudiants à moscou
mais l'été il endosse un autre costume
l'uniforme d'un travail
inimaginable ailleurs dans le monde leur
boulot se faire prendre en photo avec
des vacanciers dans un costume qui
rappelle les temps coloniaux et les
anciennes pub raciste
tous les jours ils arpentent la plage et
vont démarcher le client va bien et toi
tu veux une photo aujourd'hui
non j'en ai déjà une et c'est bon
raymond propose à ce touriste différents
styles de photos en fonction de ses
goûts
vas-y on va faire celle-là ce père vient
de décider quel pause fera sa fille mais
avant tout impossible pour sept enfants
d'échapper aux déguisements
[Musique]
et vous l'aviez comment là
la pose du cochon pendu france et pied
un classique à sotchi regarde par la
relève cette main un cliché du sauvage
cannibale mais ici ça ne choque personne
[Musique]
où est le mal
pourquoi pas pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
le faire hein dites moi pourquoi pas
mais c'est raciste de faire ça mais non
ce n'est pas du tout ça pendant trois
heures
herbert et raymond vont se faire prendre
en photo principalement avec des enfants
comme avec cette petite fille encore une
photo que son père lui offre comme un
cadeau pourquoi je pourrais pas le faire
on prend bien des photos avec des
dauphins aussi vous savez les voir
devant nous c'est inhabituel leurs
extérieurs les différents à leur couleur
de peau ce n'est pas la nôtre
nous on a la peau blanche c'est exotique
subir les insultes herbert n'a pas le
choix c'est son gagne pas c'est une
image qu'on vend entre guillemets c'est
un point de l'afrique c'est une partie
de l'afrique
mais bien sûr ça va déranger dérange
parce que c'est un travail
10 17
alors c'est un peu ce à quoi bon 2
trouve que c'est salissant il n'y a pas
que ça la pluie comme seule aiguille
l'afrique a d'autres choses à montrer
mais c'est un peu ça je vous le dis
simplement gens croisés le fai poursuivi
ils sont plus d'une dizaine par jour
par groupe de trois le plus souvent à
venir se vendre sur les plages de la mer
noire pour seulement 5 euros la photo et
la compétition est rude
parce que c'est une partie de la plage
pendant
c'est notre parti ne l'a pas où on a
commencé
c'est un peu ça parce que d'autres
groupes ont les autres pratiques
ces territoires d'al hilal
des bagarres pour défendre son
territoire parce qu'à la clé la somme
récoltée à la fin de la saison leur
permet de vivre au moins six mois à
moscou
tu gagnes combien par jour je sais pas
ça dépend
je peux faire 200 euros 400 euros c'est
dieu qui décide en réalité herbert et
ses collègues gagnerait autour de 100
euros par jour malgré tout une jolie
somme qui montre le succès d'un business
qui n'existerait qu à sotchi
le soir venu les stars de la plage se
mélangent aux touristes dans le quartier
des bars et des boîtes de nuit même sans
déguisement
ils se font aborder par les vacanciers
parfois de manière moqueuse presque
agressive viens tu me payes 23 euros
pour qu'on fasse une photo ensemble
allez viens tu me payes 23 euros pour
faire une photo avec un blanc qu'est ce
tu veux tu me prends mon téléphone alors
23 1 23 mai comprend rien en russe
on dit on te donne tu prends honteux
battu cours mais quel con celui-là alors
les insultes racistes ne sont jamais
loin pour décompresser
herbert et ses copains ont leurs
habitudes dans ce bar de la ville et
revers rêvait de la france mais le seul
pays à avoir accepté sa demande de visa
c'est la russie il est étudiant
il veut être ingénieur si on pouvait le
faire n'a plus moi je pourrais me faire
oui si c'est très dur faut se battre à
gauche à blois et puis le coût de la vie
est on est mais avec un visa étudiant
pas d'autre solution que de travailler
illégalement à sotchi
c'est un peu ça quoi et puis ça va ça
pour un boulot officielle mais on est
obligé de faire avec parce que
franchement à l'école l'année prochaine
herbert ne sait pas encore s'il réussira
à trouver un autre moyen de survivre à
6000 km de chez lui ou s'il sera obligé
de revenir l'été prochain sur les plages
de la mer noire
[Musique]
les vacances à sotchi c'est une longue
histoire russes et même soviétique
sotchi s'est depuis longtemps la ville
des td maître du kremlin
aujourd'hui poutine hier staline c'est
l'ancien dictateur communiste dans les
années 30 qui en a fait la ville à la
mode
un héritage poste urss qui se devine
encore à chaque coin de rue une histoire
au chapitre sombre aujourd'hui une
attraction pour les touristes début de
la balade sur les hauteurs de la ville
ont regardé ce panorama qui s'offre à
vous et nous suivons la logique de notre
visite
car la construction de cette tour a été
ordonné par staline
voici un tour à la gloire de staline
pour nostalgiques de l'union soviétique
olga et alexander os 27 ans tous les
deux une photo de ce côté maintenant on
devrait vraiment se construire une
maison ici
ce jeune couple vient de saint
pétersbourg dans le nord du pays la vue
s'ouvre sur la montagne et sur la mer
c'est fantastique très fort prochaine
cible
c'est leur deuxième séjour à sotchi tous
les deux fans de staline ils sont
revenus cette année pour visiter les
lieux de leur héros comme sa maison de
villégiature qu'on appelle en russe une
datcha on veut aller à la datcha de
staline
nous voudrions voir comment ils vivaient
parce que c'est un personnage historique
et sociale importante
le grand chef il a laissé une grande
trace dans le style vous savez c'est une
chose d'écouter la télévision est ce
qu'elle revienne c'est une autre de voir
tous par nos propres yeux pour aller sur
les pas de staline il faut se rendre sur
les hauteurs aux hot chip
c'est l'endroit le plus huppé de la
ville là où les inistère du régime
avaient leurs habitudes
sur votre droite l'endroit où se trouve
la résidence d'été de notre président
pour près de 50 euros
ce groupe de touristes va revivre une
page de l'histoire soviétique
le nez par là on va commencer un musée
ouvert juste après l'effondrement de
l'urss
début de la visite bienvenue chez
staline
dès l'entrée vous veniez sa salle de
travail ici tout est d'époque
[Musique]
comme ce drapeau symbole du régime
totalitaire mis en place par staline ou
encore les photos de ses amis les plus
proches comme le camarade mao dictateur
communiste chinois un mausolée qui
propose un voyage au coeur de la
propagande d'antan le chef de la patrie
ne pouvait pas être relais sous les
photos officielles
le photographe qui travaillaient avec
staline était donc très professionnel
regardez sur cette photo la conférence
de yalta churchill et staline ils ont un
fauteuil de même taille mais regardez
avec sa casquette son col relevé et son
manteau militaire
staline a l'air plus imposant que
churchill un culte de la personnalité
rendu obligatoire en urss est toujours
d'actualité 23 ans après la chute du mur
en témoigne cette statue en cire qui
nous donne à voir un staline idéalisée
en réalité il n'était pas si bien
proportionné parce que ses jambes
étaient courtes et son torse plus long
son bras gauche lui était atrophiée et
son visage était frappé par la variole
staline est mort depuis longtemps mais
il a toujours ses admirateurs même des
enfants se font prendre en photo avec un
homme dont le règne a causé la mort de
30 millions de personnes
ça te plaît oui beaucoup
je trouve ça beau c'est notre grand mère
qui nous a parlé de staline et elle vous
disais quoi elle nous disait à quel
point les mais alors on est venu voir la
visite de toute évidence plus aux fans
[Musique]
regardent
il est fait en bois naturel on pourrait
avoir le même chez nous non pour notre
bureau où il se serait très bien il en
admire les moindres détails comme dans
la salle de jeux du dictateur ça c'est
la table typique d'un billard us avec
ses règles spécifiques à chaque pièce
chaque objet sa photo souvenir
histoire de ne rien manquer de leur
idole ma première impression c'est que
c'était quelqu'un de très proche du
peuple très simple son âme est toujours
là on peut même ressentir sa présence
c'est comme s'il avait quitté les lieux
il y a à peine quelques minutes on a
l'impression que rien n'a été touché
je suis très impressionné
la datcha de staline devient l'un des
sites touristiques les plus visités
la fréquentation a doublé ces dernières
années chaque pièce à sa petite anecdote
comme les thermes privé de celui qu'on
appelait le petit père des peuples ont
dit qu'ils avaient peur de la mer mais
en fait c'est qu'il était gêné par tous
ces handicaps physiques
il ne voulait pas montrer ses infirmités
et donc comme il avait besoin de prendre
les bains thermaux
il a fait faire cette piscine qu on
remplissait à l'eau de mer avant de
quitter sotchi ancienne ville des tsars
et des apparatchiks
nous avons voulu retrouver alex hayes
l'ancien policier expulsé
un après midi du mois de juillet nous
retournons avec lui pour la première
fois sur les lieux de son ancienne
maison il ne reste plus rien voilà c'est
exactement là à cet endroit que j'avais
maison elle allait de ce coup de enfers
jusque là ce que je ressens j'ai été au
service de mon pays
on m'a jeté assez à manger dans un chien
la rue
[Musique]
son fils a dû partir vivre avec son
ex-femme à des centaines de km de sotchi
il vit désormais seul et sans domicile
fixe tout ce qui lui reste il entassés
dans ses garages aux abords du site
il y à peine un mois celui ci a été
cambriolé
[Musique]
on peut regarder tout est dit renversé
tout a été fouillé ce qu'il me reste
c'est ça ça c'est ma grand-mère et ça
c'est mon père c'est tout ce qu'ils
m'ont laissé ses photos ils n'ont rien
respecté alex klein n'a reçu aucune
compensation ni offre de relogement sa
dernière chance la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme pour l'instant il n'a
obtenu aucune réponse rien de toute
façon on arrêtera le compte à rebours
les jeux sont bien trop important pour
la russie de vladimir poutine
du 7 au 23 février trois milliards de
téléspectateurs auront les yeux braqués
sur la riviera russe
[Musique]